it's time to look at the kubernetes api
and how it makes modeling the
application lifecycle
easier with a whole universe of things
to learn it's important to start with
the essentials
let's go over the concepts that make
kubernetes usable scalable and just
downright awesome
are you ready caslin when it comes to
what scalable applications need
we've talked about containers and nodes
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
there's plenty more we need in order to
run a full scalable application
exactly and that's where the kubernetes
api comes in
it offers some really convenient
primitives that make managing
cloud-native applications
a lot easier we've already talked about
a few api
objects like pods and nodes but there's
also services
deployments secrets and many more
that's a lot why don't we start simple
and use an example application
we said that containers are the first
step to using kubernetes so let's start
with this container i built to run my
hello app
this app is really simple it just
returns hello whenever i ping it on his
local ip and port 8080
so what next well the first thing we
have to do
is to create some machines or nodes to
run your application on
gotcha okay i'll use google kubernetes
engine to quickly get started
i can just use the gcloud command line
tool to provision a kubernetes cluster
after a few minutes we'll have a cluster
that's all ready to go and by default
comes with three nodes this is a great
starting point
but now we need to actually run my app
so how do we do that
since we're using the command line we
can use a handy tool called
cubectl to help interact with the
kubernetes api
don't worry we'll go into ctl in more
detail later
but we're keeping it simple remember
what about all these other tools i've
heard of
cube control cube cuddle cube ectel
there are a lot of different ways to
pronounce the name of this tool
so whatever works for you anyway this
command
is actually going to create a kubernetes
api object
called a deployment a deployment is an
abstraction that manages the lifecycle
of an application
i can set the desired number of app
instances for the deployment to manage
and then it will make sure the correct
number of instances or replicas
are running exactly so if we increase
the number of replicas that we want
the deployment will see that there's
currently not enough replicas
and spin up another one that even works
when a node crashes
if the node goes down the current state
is once again different from the desired
state
and kubernetes will schedule another
replica for us
awesome now i know my app is running on
these nodes
how do i access it for that we'll have
to create a service
this creates an endpoint that we can use
to access the running app instances
in this case we have multiple app
instances
so this service will load balance
incoming requests between
the two running pods that's right
for any container inside of the cluster
they can connect to my service using the
service's name
either way the service keeps track of
wherever the positives are running
that's another example of how kubernetes
removes the need to manually keep track
of where your containers are running
even if a pod were to go down once a new
one comes back online
the service will automatically update
its list of endpoints to target the new
pod
so kubernetes objects like deployments
and services
automatically ensure that we have the
right number of app instances running
through pods and that we can always
reach them this seems like it would
allow for some really cool features
yes features that used to have to be
manually coded
just become afterthoughts when using
kubernetes for example
deployments make things like rolling
updates really simple
whoa you're saying that we can edit the
deployment and watch the version of the
applications gradually change
so let's say we have three replicas and
and i want to put out a new version of
my application
that returns by instead of hello you're
saying i can update my application
container
watch as the new version is gradually
rolled out
and the deployment will bring up new
application instances
and start rerouting traffic to them then
once the desired number of new instances
are online
the old application instances are taken
offline
this would mean this approach has zero
downtime since kubernetes is
incrementally updating
old pod instances with new ones exactly
right
and a feature like that plus the ability
to quickly roll back if necessary
and keeping track of deployment
histories and more
all of that is just built into
kubernetes that's a large part of what
makes it such a great tool to build
other systems and applications on top of
the kubernetes api really does make it
easy to manage application lifecycle
the basic primitives pods service
deployments plus a few more we'll talk
about soon
allow sysadmins and developers to focus
on the app
without having to worry about managing
it at scale but
one thing i noticed is that we used an
imperative approach
we made manual commands instead of using
a declarative approach
which is one of the big appeals of
kubernetes great catch
next episode let's dig into that we'll
use kubernetes the way it was intended
to be used
by updating config files starting with
an example monolith
we'll break it up into a microservices
style architecture
this will also let us introduce some of
the other core primitives that we didn't
talk about
like labels and secrets we're gonna pair
code up a micro microservice versions of
this
okay stay tuned everybody next time
we'll be exploring building a basic
kubernetes app from scratch
in the meantime if you want to get hands
on check out the link in the description
and if you enjoyed the episode subscribe
for more